by 2030 scientists predict there'll be 1
billion more people in the world so
where are they going to live the
greatest population expansions are
expected to happen in African and Asian
cities many of which are already very
overcrowded so they can't go there two
researchers in the States set out to
build a map of potential places to put
the next billion people first they ruled
out regions with high water stress land
covered in ice and places with unique
species that need protecting
then they excluded densely settled areas
where there are more than a hundred
people per square kilometer what they
are left with are zones deemed suitable
for sustainable development some classed
is highly sustainable and some as
somewhat sustainable but it isn't quite
that simple
large areas of Central Africa fit the
bill with lots of natural resources but
at the moment these areas are poorly
governed and there are few jobs another
promising swathe of land is in South
America on one hand the warm moist
climate could support crops like rice
and maize great for feeding lots of
hungry mouths on the other hand nearby
biodiversity hotspots like the Amazon
basin need protecting there are similar
conservation concerns in species rich
northern Queensland and finding suitable
land isn't the only challenge as recent
refugee crises in the Middle East
demonstrate relocating people from their
homelands to new shores is not easy
politically emotionally or practically
also the habitable zones on this map
span multiple countries and it's unclear
how governments would work together to
encourage migration there or to house
people there are other options like
creating yet more compact cities
supplied with water from yet deeper
wells or desalination plants but some
argue that this would be unsustainable
in the long term what is clear is that
the next billion people will need to
live somewhere and urban planners
scientists and politicians will need to
work together to plan where it's going
to be